you're just talking about this the
weather warming up we're starting to see
more outdoor concerts but we do have a
temperature heads up for you and while
most of us locals know how to handle the
heat a lot of folks need to be aware of
staying safe and visitors from out of
town they're going to be partying this
weekend mary jane belliesa is live now
on the strip where the newest concert
lovers and friends will be held this
weekend good morning mary jane
good morning sherry and nate you know i
was just jamming out in the car i was
telling armando our photographer that i
was listening to some usher to kind of
get into the mood for the lovers and
friends festival you can actually see
the stage right behind me and you know
with the festival kicking off this
weekend there's some serious excitement
but that also comes with serious
preparation to ensure everyone stays
safe as triple digit temperatures are
expected now dr mark j khan the dean at
kirk akorian school of medicine says
hydration will play a key role if you're
spending time outdoors he says alcohol
and soda can dehydrate the body so take
sips in moderation because our
perspiration evaporates so quickly in
southern nevada we may not always be
aware of our water loss
people should drink eight to ten glasses
of water a day but that doesn't take
into account our low humidity and the
high temperatures we're going to have
this weekend you know i think what's
really important is if you're outside
you need to be drinking water probably
all the time you know even up to 10
liters of water a day may be required
based on our heat and humidity
you can also beat the heat and stay cool
by wearing light-colored and loose
clothing and keeping your face protected
by wearing a hat and sunglasses too and
we also have well a number of security
personnel as well as fire and police if
you have any questions while you're at
the festival this weekend reporting live
from the strip mary jane vallezza live
local now